this is Rachel on the rocks I never
really predicted jury back in the day I
never would on trains an entire person
I might go holiday like with no jury but
when I made it in my profession it was
just something let me know hey I'm
successful with this looks like a gold
medal you know it's like let anybody
know damn I won first place I want I
want a prize like it's a compliment you
know saying I ain't never really looked
up to artists that were trans cuz it
wasn't like never a big thing to me but
I did like jury like you know I like the
way it look I got these two watches they
bust down I always wanted that you know
and so now I got it for myself
now I can combine them cuz like you know
saying two heads is better than one got
now I got two heads I got to watch faces
on my own my head being you know saying
I got this envisions to watch goggles I
brought a goggles back clicking Shore
head I broke these you know I said I'm
sorry GQ you know yeah but this is the
coolest piece of jewelry in the whole
rap game period I got a autumn are and I
got at home yeah Master Rosie and I just
combined them and that's like some
goggles I put them on my head
a headband you know that being a party
my head is little a hundred thousand on
my head black nerd so crazy man I was
onstage we did some with each other
I got him on my forehead so they heavy
that's one thing about him the heavy I
had them tight on my forehead so they
fell on my forehead they hit my nose and
then I got this little cut off my nose
you know if you can see it scar my nose
a little bit and I look down I seen him
hanging like this so I just said okay
cool I got your pics
I was on a vacation I couldn't bring my
favorite piece of jewelry wit me I mean
I had to leave it in the fish tank I
just fit it it's my fish ball and chain
you know it seems crazy nobody ever did
it it's exclusive fossilized fish you
know saying play didn't go weird I'm
alone it's crazy just an elegant piece
and I'm saying yo can we go to shame
I know it's I know we can Google to
change slightly fish bowling knickers
just put on you see here you know
staying here here perfect slide I went
over here and then this is a ap I don't
want forget buzz down to time and I got
this because I'm Jimmy got this person
he was at the club one day we got and I
had a roadie and I was just looking at
his wrist and I said hey bro that's
really kind of outdoing my roadie
so the next day I just went to the jury
shop I said yo I want to get exactly my
brother gun weight winning between it
twinning and winning yeah moving on you
know I got the gym chain it's my name
tag you know we used to go to work you
have a name tag so I had always gonna
have like on all golden name tag so when
you look at me they be like Jim when you
hear Jimmy be like ji you know you
notice there's a few dogs you like Jay I
am sorry like not just put the X in the
X is for excellent Jim you know I'm
saying this is actually the second
version of this chain I got first one I
was like so I thought one day I was
telling my friends cuz I hate to kept
telling me they may take your chain off
when you stage God doesn't case your
chain break song I'm saying it came free
can I pull it like this and I popped two
of the little things I was holding it
together the first thing I want to do is
jump in the crowd so I jump in the crowd
when I jump in the crowd the last one of
these pop off and my chain fall and then
is going and I don't even know until I
get back to the to the stage and then
I'm over there looking say a great like
now I've told you man I told you man
like you know saying but yeah it was
crazy man a rock star lifestyle might
not make it every day get wasted
so this ring right here there's my
pinkie ring you know you got had a
freshest pinkie ring it's a panda coin
it's supposedly rare you know I'm saying
so it's in the middle of this surrounded
by little diamonds most of my rings are
like wedding rings you know saying like
marry I'm gonna be made
so I'm gonna take one these rings off
and I'm just put it directly on my wife
and propose my second favorite this is
one of the first rings I ever bought and
it never came up as you can see it's a
man you guys are engagement wedding bent
like a man because I'm married to this
lifetime I'm married to the guy I'm
married to the music right now this
right here is a piece of yellow diamond
you got to really get close on it mr. C
its hydrated like the piece is hydrated
piece though so it's light light yellow
sorry for that graphic language he needs
to just write here like I got these my
first time going to Dubai they just like
stones like jewels ain't even diamonds I
just big stones and these two right here
I say didn't got down some kind of
pointers they big they dance like like
hippies they didn't cha-cha slide when
you like it be my buddy fungi I got this
ear drummer records cuz it's the
greatest we did greatest you knows where
we started he's my family so this is my
piece you know I'm saying but I broke it
onstage also that's why I don't really
wear a lot of jury I don't be buying a
lot of jury because right now thanks for
wild I keep breaking everything you know
that is broken but a GQ I love you I
woke up stupid drunk left watches in my
hotel rooms I don't look up
faded I don't want to sleep on a plane
took my chain off on the plane woke up
and forgot to put my chain back on so my
chain left on the plane the plane and
took off to a whole nother state new
people sitting on it ain't never gonna
see anything you know I realize so much
change so much drew got lost one time I
had it bigger like it was like a
Lamborghini on a ring it's like early
jury days though and I was in South by
Southwest and I was just I came on stage
I was like he looks big for me the whole
time when I bought is looked at me like
I gonna be cool so damn boom got on
stage did my jeweler calling me right
now
got on stage goddamn got turned up i
fund my arms up like that and the ring
just went way up and I seen it go up in
the air and then just
the backyard next to me it was a
backyard like performance in
side-by-side with sort of ring women
like 20 feet up in their iPhone my arms
up
I'm just sitting there watching it bomb
and just landed in the backyard and I
got my two bracelets right here you know
I'm saying I don't never wear these I
had got on one time I don't know why I
got them but I don't never wear but I
love you know I say the same way I put
them up and then I got my itchy
they're just cars got my Gucci links
there's a flex to it like because I
don't never wear this neither I don't
know why sure like magic my name's egg
in my head like a lot of my jury are
gifts like my brother got me this slim
jim he got me just ready street they was
one bracelet and then I had chopped him
in this into three couldn't wear it was
so buzzed down when I first got it as
one can wear it so I had it for two
years I'm like rocking your like say it
was like something there's like it
looked like a it's so big like like a
wristband it was amazing it was like the
early Blue Cheer is very light it was
crazy
and these two little blue stones these
are aquamarines right here you know any
blue stones I got these in Coachella
like my third time for Nicole chillin
I got it from a random jewelry a random
jury shop just random in the desert I
stopped down like yeah let me see what
kind of jewelry guy mister best like a
Hannah store saw cop that aquamarines
they blue oh wait my quill got me this
to this is on Cartier bracelet of the
newest knows one well yeah my boy my we
look you got me this giant you knows
what these things were here be costing
too much I came to my ear area and this
of course you gotta know what this is
shrim like now you know what the [ __ ]
that is
shrim life and this is like we got
shrimp like because this is our
lifestyle is the way we exist shrim life
like the everyday we just wake up a
little shrimp
you